[Aplausos]
[Música]
el miedo a quedarse sin petróleo fue
durante décadas uno de los pronósticos
más recurrentes y al mismo tiempo que
más titulares alarma y controversia
generaba incluso era motivo de estudio o
al menos advertencia hasta en las
propias escuelas os acordáis quizás lo
fuera en buena medida porque la
disponibilidad de fuentes de energía
aprovechable era mucho más limitada de
lo que es hoy en día y de hecho tanto es
así que como los malos augurios nunca se
cumplían las profecías se fueron
retrasando una y otra y otra vez algún
día tendría que llegar el tan ansiado
fin del petróleo mundo se va a quedar
sin petróleo en diez años la oficina de
minas de eeuu en 1914 el mundo se va a
quedar sin petróleo en 13 años oficina
de minas de eeuu en 1939 y 1950 el mundo
se va a quedar sin petróleo y otros
combustibles fósiles en 1990
paul ehrlich los límites del crecimiento
en 1973
en el mundo se va a quedar sin petróleo
en 2030 y sin combustibles fósiles en
2050 paul ehrlich más allá del límite el
2002 como veis no dieron ni una por
supuesto lo que toda esta gente no tuvo
nunca en cuenta fue la evolución
tecnológica que el ser humano iba a
seguir alimentando con el paso de los
años
[Música]
y no solo hablamos del petróleo el miedo
a quedarse sin una fuente de energía
abundante fue una constante entre
periodistas analistas y expertos de todo
tipo de hecho hoy cuando hablamos de los
combustibles fósiles lo que más nos
suele importar es la contaminación pero
lo cierto es que durante años no fue una
cuestión de conciencia ambiental sino de
miedo miedo a quedarse sin suministro en
cualquier caso la cuestión es que
estamos en pleno siglo 21 y salvo por la
energía nuclear todo el mundo parece
correr hacia un futuro sin energías
fósiles todo el mundo no todo el mundo
no al mejor estilo de la aldea de
asterix un país poblado por
irreductibles samuráis resiste contra
viento y marea queridos amigos amigas de
visual polític durante los últimos años
japón ha ido en contra de la tendencia
global y no sólo no ha reducido su
consumo de combustibles fósiles sino que
lo ha incrementado
2011 fue para japón una especie de punto
y aparte el terremoto y el posterior
tsunami con sus devastadores efectos
sobre la central nuclear de fukushima
cambiaron el planteamiento energético
del país si hasta ese momento los
japoneses abrazaba la energía luego ya
la cosa fue diferente querían buscar
alternativas
el incidente de fukushima se saldó con
muchos de los reactores nucleares del
país detenidos situación que se prolonga
hasta el día de hoy evidentemente toda
esa energía tuvo que ser suplida de
alguna manera si con renovables pero
también inicialmente con petróleo y gas
muchísimo gas
tanto fue así que en 2016 las fuentes de
energía primaria procedentes de
combustibles fósiles llegaron a suponer
más del 90 por ciento de todo el consumo
nacional lo que en un país con tan pocos
recursos naturales aprovechables como
japón supuso tener que cubrir con
importaciones más del 80 por ciento de
todas sus necesidades energéticas japón
es uno de los países energéticamente más
dependientes del mundo
el caso es que eso hizo saltar todas las
alarmas en tokio y no es que se tratara
de una cuestión medioambiental sino
también y sobre todo en una cuestión
estratégica económica y geopolítica y es
que para un país como japón depender
íntegramente del suministro de
combustibles fósiles de origen
extranjero y traídos por barco supone un
enorme riesgo para la seguridad nacional
especialmente en un momento en el que
sin fin ha puesto patas arriba a la
geopolítica en esta región del mundo
amigos amigas durante años los políticos
japoneses apostaron por la energía
nuclear como la mejor fórmula para ganar
autonomía pero qué ocurre si ya no
quieres o electoralmente no puedes
contar con ella
digamos que hoy por hoy no es la fuente
de energía precisamente más popular en
japón y precisamente por eso se lanzaron
en masa a desarrollar las energías
renovables como si no hubiera mañana
especialmente la energía solar pero
claro sustituir la energía nuclear son
pala
mayores así que la pregunta la gran
pregunta que podemos hacernos es cuál es
la solución que los japoneses han puesto
sobre la mesa en que han pensado
exactamente tienen alguna idea original
[Música]
pues aunque pueda sorprender te una de
las hipótesis una de las soluciones que
manejan todo este embrollo pasa por
convertirse en algo así como los nuevos
x del gas si convertirse en grandes
productores a toda costa pero hay un
problema no tienen gas no al menos lo
que todos conocemos como el gas natural
convencional y justo aquí en este
preciso instante ha llegado la hora de
poner sobre la mesa la que puede
convertirse en una de las grandes
apuestas estratégicas de japón el
hidrato de metano alguna vez habías
escuchado hablar de este compuesto
verdad que la mayoría de vosotros no me
equivoco pues presta atención porque os
vamos a contar en qué consiste cómo se
puede aprovechar y qué demonios están
pensando en japón atentos
[Música]
el hielo inflamable
si lo habéis escuchado bien no nos hemos
vuelto locos existe un hielo que si lo
quemas prende se llama hidrato de metano
y lo hay en cantidades enormes a lo
largo y ancho de todo el planeta
concretamente debajo del lecho oceánico
y ojo porque esto último es lo que lo
convierte en una de las materias primas
más deseadas pero al mismo tiempo
también más controvertidas al fin y al
cabo en el lecho oceánico no sólo
existen ecosistemas tan únicos como
frágiles sino que además extraer
materias primas de él es una operación
que conlleva muchos riesgos pero para
entender la importancia que tiene este
recurso tenemos que aparcar aunque sea
por un momento las consideraciones
ambientales y centrarnos en su enorme
potencial que la verdad creo puede
sorprendernos el hidrato de metano es la
fuente de carbono más abundante de la
tierra se estima que aglutina un tercio
de todo el carbono del planeta y ojo
porque las estimaciones en torno a las
reservas globales del hidrato de metano
del departamento de energía de los
estado
y dos apuntan a que su poder energético
podría superar al de todos los demás
combustibles fósiles conocidos quizás
por ello china está realizando pruebas
de extracción de este recurso en el mar
de china meridional y de hecho es algo
que pekín podría estar teniendo en
cuenta a la hora de extender sus
reclamaciones marítimas sin embargo
hablamos de un compuesto que es
altamente inestable muy inflamable y
particularmente sensible a la presión ya
la temperatura características que hacen
que su extracción no sea ni mucho menos
algo tan sencillo como emplear la
minería tradicional es decir excavar
recogerlo y transportarlo a tierra firme
ahora bien porque hablamos de japón y no
de otros países cuando nos referimos a
este hielo inflamable puedes echar un
vistazo atentamente a este mapa para
poder entenderlo cada uno de los puntos
verdes hacen referencia a depósitos
conocidos de hidrato de metano en el
mundo tal y como podéis ver la mayor
concentración conocida de esta materia
prima se sitúa precisamente en torno a
japón la costa nipona está literalmente
salpicada por depósitos de este
compuesto lo que en gran medida se debe
a la confluencia de placas tectónicas ya
los enormes depósitos sedimentarios que
hay frente a su costa no todo iba a ser
malo algo bueno tenía que tener ser una
de las zonas con más riesgo sísmico del
planeta no os parece
y
[Música]
pues ya lo veis en este caso la
compensación es que japón es uno de los
países con mayores reservas de hidrato
de metano todo el planeta para que os
hagáis una idea el gobierno japonés
calcula que su territorio hay por lo
menos siete billones de metros cúbicos
de hidrato de metano en depósitos
offshore eso podría llegar a ser
suficiente como para satisfacer todo el
consumo de gas de japón durante casi un
siglo
insisto podría haber mucho más hidrato
precisamente por eso hay pocas dudas
acerca de que la extracción de hidratos
de metano podría garantizar el
suministro energético por mucho
muchísimo tiempo y evidentemente no sólo
en japón pero un momento porque no nos
resulta tan sencillo el problema es que
todavía no se sabe muy bien cómo
aprovecharlo especialmente cómo
extraerlo y procesarlo pues bien hoy por
hoy para hacerlo hay dos formas una
llamémoslo convencional y otra digamos
un poquito más revolucionaria que es la
que japón está intentando desarrollar
la manera tradicional consiste en
extraer este recurso mediante
perforaciones de lecho marino en
profundidades de unos 1000 metros además
hay que tener en cuenta que los
depósitos no se encuentran en el agua
sino que se sitúan a unos cuantos
cientos de metros por debajo del lecho
marino lo que implica una complejidad
adicional y unos costes tan elevados que
a día de hoy no permiten que esta opción
sea comercialmente viable y luego está
la forma más revolucionaria que es en la
que está trabajando japón empresas como
modelo mitsubishi shipbuilding están
desarrollando barcos extractores que
sean capaces de extraer de forma segura
los depósitos de hidratos de metano más
cercanos a la costa esto se haría
pinchando el lecho marino hasta llegar
al depósito y dejar que el hidrato de
metano ascienda el barco extractor que a
su vez podría apoyarse en otros barcos
auxiliares para transportarlo a la costa
o incluso almacenarlo y transformarlo en
gas metano in situ
parece siempre verdad pues lo cierto es
que no lo es en absoluto la complejidad
técnica viene sobre todo como ya
comentábamos antes por la inestabilidad
de este recurso y también por el riesgo
de contaminación ya que de no hacerlo
bien podrían ser liberadas altas
cantidades de metano al mar y luego a la
atmósfera y claro esto no es bueno ni
lejos ni cerca de la costa pero cerca es
que es todavía peor
[Música]
además más allá de los riesgos la
extracción en sí misma resulta
complicada incluso técnicamente digamos
que durante el proceso de perforación se
corre el riesgo de que entre arena o
cualquier otra cosa al depósito a través
de la perforación y eso podría
desestabilizar el hidrato de metano
hasta el punto de volverlo inutilizable
pero en fin es en lo que están
trabajando el objetivo es conseguir gas
gas y más gas y que sea lo más barato
posible para los nipones pero ojo porque
nos falta un detalle clave lo que japón
aspira es a convertirse en toda una
potencia productora de hidrógeno
produciendo lo precisamente con el gas
extraído de los depósitos de hidrato de
metano vamos un yo me lo guiso yo me lo
como en toda regla y tal y como ya os
contamos en un vídeo que publicamos hace
poco tiempo sobre el hidrógeno el cual
por cierto os dejo aquí abajo en la
descripción las implicaciones podrían
ser enormes pero un momento si estamos
hablando de hidrato de metano y demonios
pinta aquí el hidrógeno pues atentos
ah
el trampolín hipona hacia el hidrógeno
amigos tal y como os contamos en el
vídeo del hidrógeno este combustible se
puede producir de varias maneras
diferentes la más frecuente es
producirlo utilizando carbón gas natural
o más recientemente también energías
renovables pues bien he aquí la clave de
las intenciones energéticas de japón
extraer hidrato de metano y utilizarlo
para producir hidrógeno para que os
hagáis una idea un metro cúbico de
hidratos de metano puede producir
aproximadamente 160 metros cúbicos de
gas metano que después se pueden
transformar asimismo en hidrógeno de
esta forma a países con amplios
depósitos de hidratos de metano tal y
como es el caso de japón podrían
transitar muy rápidamente hacia el
hidrógeno y utilizarlo como combustible
limpio y no dependiente de las
importaciones
[Música]
de hecho el hidrógeno es un pilar cada
vez más importante en la estrategia
energética del gobierno de japón el cual
espera estimular el consumo de este
combustible por encima de las 20
millones de toneladas para el 2050 un
objetivo relativamente elevado
especialmente si tenemos en cuenta que
por unidad de peso la potencia
energética del hidrógeno es tres veces
la de la gasolina pero que sólo será
posible alcanzar si se logran reducir
sustancialmente sus costes de producción
de esta forma el plan del gobierno nipón
pasa por reducir de 100 a 20 yenes por
metro cúbico el coste de producción del
hidrógeno esto es de 91 a 18 centavos de
dólar y para lograr ese objetivo entre
otras cosas el país necesita un
suministro de energía muy competitivo
potencialmente el hidrato de metano y no
sólo eso además producir hidrógeno con
el gas derivado del hidrato de metano
sería más limpio que hacerlo con otras
fuentes ya que el hidrato de metano
emite un 30% menos de dióxido de carbono
cuando se quema que el carbón o el
petróleo
[Música]
la cuestión es será posible aprovechar
el hidrato de metano a escala comercial
y que sea económicamente viable y luego
otra pregunta que hay que hacerse es
podrà el hidrógeno acelerar su despegue
gracias al hidrato de metano japón se
fija en el hielo inflamable submarino
como fuente de hidrógeno de combustión
limpia pues amigos ésta es la revolución
energética a la que está tratando de
subirse japón
[Música]
una técnica que luego se complementaría
con las tecnologías de captura de
carbono y es que de esta forma japón
podría lograr una enorme autonomía
energética ahora bien será algún día
viable no está claro pero por lo pronto
en 2017 el país del sol naciente
consiguió a través de su proyecto
experimental en la fosa de nankai
extraer hidrato de metano durante 24
días sin ninguna incidencia técnica y no
sólo eso el gobierno cree que conseguirá
arrancar proyectos comerciales con
hidrato de metano entre los años 2000 23
y 2027 o al menos eso es lo que dice su
último plan estratégico de energía por
lo pronto llegados hasta aquí y turno
para ti crees que deberíamos aprovechar
a escala masiva el gas que está dormido
en los depósitos de hidratos de metano o
crees que bajo ningún concepto se
deberían realizar extracciones de este
tipo por los riesgos ambientales que
conlleva déjanos tu opinión aquí abajo
en los comentarios y como siempre si
este vídeo te ha resultado interesante
háznoslo saber dame al botón de like y
suscríbete a visual política si aún no
lo has hecho una vez más gracias por
estar ahí un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]